[Music]
let's go to lacey in iowa what's up
lacey
hey how's it going we're partying how
about you
um
trying to do the same a little bit at a
time
very cool what's up
so in the great words of whitney houston
i want to feel the heat with somebody in
particular
hey listen this is amazing but uh i went
to this incredible uh
uh heavy metal concert thing like this
this hardcore show and that was the
intro song like all the lights go down
and that's the song they played and i
smiled from ear to ear and thought this
show's going to be incredible and the
fact that you just brought that up is
just perfect so good for you all right
let's get back into it okay so you want
to party husband's not so down tell me
more
i would say my husband wants to try to
be down to the party but
we've been together for about nine ten
years five of those married
and
we have
tried
every avenue imaginable to not only like
increase the
romance dating life but also the
intimacy
realm
and i have particular preferences that
are probably not safe to say on uh
public
podcasts but yeah they are
very particular hold on you
remember back in middle school when
somebody would like be like hey
lacie
um i know someone who likes you and uh
i'm never gonna tell you and they just
leave
you can't do that you can't call and be
like i've got this crazy thing and then
everybody every listen number one
nobody's listening to this show we all
know that right um and number two
you can't just drop that so what what is
your
thing
my sexual um
tendencies are more risque into the
abbreviations of bdsm
and
i i have always had that interest and
i've learned to dial back to meet my
husband's needs because he has never had
any other sexual partners aside from me
and he only had one other long-term
relationship before me and that was just
in high school so
um he has spent the last you know nine
ten years learning with me how to do the
things that i need and would like and in
turn you know i do the things that he
enjoys and likes however
in in very plain terms i mean he's
always vanilla he likes his same old
same old and he's just a sappy heartfelt
guy that's he's just a big cuddler and
i'm
i'm really the opposite of that i'm like
every touch of the skin could
it just sets my soul on fire and i'm
like what's coming next i'm just alive
and ready for more
and with him it doesn't really go any
more than that so
i guess we're just rolling around in
like the same routines and we have been
for a long time and it got pretty bad
about a year and a half ago
we had you know just kind of came to the
conclusion that beyond therapy and
medications and all kinds of
session treatments that we
just weren't compatible in that realm
and it really hurt my heart because i
love the daylights out of this guy and
he loves me endlessly and we didn't want
to call it quits just because you know
we weren't
romantically connected in the same ways
and we just felt like we were living
like like roommates almost you know like
come home do the tours do your
day-to-day job and you know chat about
your day and that was it
so we're just trying to find
a new way to make
us compatible in that way and i i don't
know if that sounds weird to say out
loud but no not wrong i'm just i'm stuck
i don't i don't know what else to do
that would get him to want to
participate in the ways that i need both
in the dating world and in the intimacy
realm
so i'm not living that same old
regurgitated vanilla lifestyle that i'm
just not so in love with
you're so uh
the way you're so descriptive and it's
beautiful
the regurgitated vanilla that's the kind
of sex that everybody likes is
regurgitated vanilla
god
almighty um okay so
man there's so much here i i
you and i could talk for a couple hours
um and you're a joy to talk to so number
one thank you um
being into what you're into with your
husband i
i i really
don't want you to
you're coming at this with a specter of
shame or a specter of weird and maybe
it's just you're just trying to be
respectful of this show and stuff like
that so um there's nothing that i say
that every time i say nothing i'm always
surprised um
very few things surprise me when a
couple gets together and like like hey
we've been we've been married for five
years or nine years and
i this is kind of what does it for me
everybody's different the challenge like
you mentioned is how do i say this out
loud how do i let my needs be
spoken into being and how do i let
somebody hear them and then how do we
figure out what comes next right that's
the hard part and so i like to think of
intimacy as just about closing the gap
reaching across whatever
you know gap of discomfort there is and
saying this is me this is all of me are
you still in right
right what i hear you conflating
is romance intimacy
and
sexual preference
and i think
when you conflate the three of those
three things like that they all they all
are linked but when you conflate all
three of them you find yourself in a
position where you can never be happy
you see what i'm saying
yeah
every single thing is sexually charged
with you is that right
you said every time like he can walk by
you in the kitchen and just put his hand
on your hip as he's trying to get around
you and you're like it's on now is that
right yes
okay
um and
he can also not do that and you begin to
wonder what's wrong is that fair or no
yes
okay where does that stem from
um i have a medical condition called
polycystic ovarian syndrome and part of
that comes from
um in
a bad balance of hormones i shouldn't
say bad but it's just very abnormal um
and so i have the testosterone of two
men yeah don't ever ever ever say
they're bad things never say they're bad
is that cool right this is this is just
your this is just how you roll
yeah yes it's different it's different
than most women i know so they they're
like geez this is you you want what yeah
and
of the spectrum of people listening you
know i can imagine there's a cluster of
men going what what this exists right so
i get that and
then right but there's also reality to
it too right
yeah which is hard
um
okay my husband and i have had very
cordial conversations about it and very
like
deep conversations so much so that i
explain i've showed pictures and videos
we've
you know we've gone through the whole
gamut of you know different means of
therapy and talking things out so i'm
not ashamed to talk about it i'm not
embarrassed or anything like that even
to friends and family who are honest and
really want to know so i mean he knows
exactly exactly what i'm looking for but
it's just hard for him to have that
desire to do those things because it's
just not in his nature he's just a lover
he's not like a
hard and heavy person like i'm even i'm
looking forward hard and heavy people
don't always like being hit
or
the one that i've heard over time is
they don't feel comfortable
hitting somebody out you know what i
mean so it's it's both
right
and
um
so here's the hard question
how old are you
i'm going to be 30 in a year in less
than a year here's the hard hard
question
are you going to leave them
i don't want to no no
because i know the last couple years
you've had this thought you wouldn't be
calling me
are you gonna leave him
no okay
here's why that answer the answer to
that is very very important because then
it reframes how much work we're going to
do how we're going to re
re-imagine this conversation because
right now this is about a particular sex
act that you want that he won't do or
let's be honest like with if you're
fully down the bdsm rabbit hole it's a
context and it's an environment that you
like right
and it is
a particular um
power hierarchy right whether it's a sub
or a there's a whole lineage here right
right and yep it's a whole context
and so if you are all in on this person
and together you all do not create this
context what you have to be willing to
do is to say okay how do i get
a
super charged libido how do i get my
idle crave
contact
and i crave um uh what i would call an
increased heart rate is that fair
yep like i if it's not and by the way
you know the the how this thing rolls
right it just increases because i got to
keep pushing that boundary right
so
how do i
create an environment where we do that
on terms that don't also isolate
my
husband and so we're not trying to
figure out ways that he can
dress up and things that make him feel
uncomfortable not trying to figure out
ways that he can
um
hit me or be hit in ways that
make him freak out that's not what we're
trying to do sure we're not trying to
accomplish this particular sect what
we're trying to do is find new
environments
the masterpiece is the book come as you
are by emily nagotsky have you read that
book
no but i've heard you mention it many
times so i'm eager to read it here's why
that book is so important i think both
of y'all need to read it together here's
why that book is important
you think of this in terms of sex strife
and that you have a high one he has a
low one is that fair
yes what she did for me was reframe the
entire thing and sex isn't about drive
at all it's environmental it's all it's
ecological in a way it's it is
how do i create a world where there's as
few offs as possible and a few ons as
possible and what that does with
somebody with a particular sexual fetish
is it begins to let them stop focusing
on that object or that thing or that
this one singular environment and begin
to look at a bigger picture okay i'm
trying to think of um
this is somebody who gets amped up in
the only way
they just in high school um they were a
weightlifter on the football team and so
they're 48 now and all they can do is
lift weights and all of a sudden both
shoulders blow out and they go to rehab
and stuff but they can't lift heavy like
they used to and that that their body
still needs that release
and so they learn
how to get that release cycling or
wrestling or rowing or any number of
other things that's what we're doing
here not because inherently the thing's
wrong but inherently that particular
environment makes your husband feel less
than or um
scared or frightened or whatever and you
love him too much to do that
is that fair
so are you willing to consider
alternative environments
yes that still includes ask for those
okay as well and i think those that
definitely makes him uncomfortable
because in his like you know vanilla
nature
where he's comfortable is
exactly where he's comfortable not that
loose performance function outside of
that area but
you know it takes a lot longer to build
up the
energy and the
the the rush to get going in a place
outside of norm so yes so he's gonna
have to also reimagine this thing too
and be willing to lean in and say okay
this particular actions in this
particular environment i can't get there
i've tried i can't get there
we figure out other ways
that at this moment or like what
can we just cuddle have boring married
person sex can we just do that right
it may be that um
there is some sort of uh we're gonna
create a um
deck of cards and we're gonna put a
particular act on it and we're just
gonna draw out of the deck and my heart
rate will get up hoping that it's this
one and his heart rate will get up
hoping it's um that we're gonna lay here
and watch the office whatever the thing
is but we're going to do these things
together that are going to create a
context that our heart rates are going
to get up and that you're going to get
the skin to skin and the um
the
if i i'm trying to say words that
instantly roll into like sound like sex
acts words but that's not what i mean
but i mean the visceral response right
that your body craves okay right um
this is less about hey we need to go
find some new videos and this is more
about i want you guys to reimagine the
whole spectrum here so do me this favor
number one know that you're not broken
and he isn't either
number two this isn't about trying to
dial up his sex drive or dial yours back
number three
bdsm is a proxy
for
an environment that gets you skin to
skin contact that makes you able to put
your head in a different psychological
place that gets a
um that is rough and that gets your body
moving in a different way right so where
can we create can we set that proxy
aside for a second and begin to create a
new environment where we still get those
things but everybody's okay and i know
you're thinking dude i've had this
conversation with him a million times
i want you all to read this book
together
and begin to say okay
um maybe it's
we go
once a month we go get a hotel room
somewhere and it looks like this or
maybe like i said we have five things in
an envelope and we draw one out once a
week and we no matter what's going on we
do that thing
or
maybe it's
different parts of the house or in the
car in the garage any number of places
and things you can do or you can go
let's begin thinking outside the box and
what you're going to do is not close
your box you're going to begin to
look at
other options and he's going to begin to
expand his
and you are going to look at this as a
series of brakes and gas pedals
how can i turn more of the ons on
and more of the offs off
a couple of exercises that dr nagaski
has in the book is
let's get beneath the
fetish and say what are the things here
that are turning you on
let's do a step let's be real clear
let's write them down
what are the things he gets by cuddling
and closeness and
as you say regurgitated vanilla how do
you all get to those places
write those things down and let's start
to look for overlap here and say okay oh
we both meet in the middle here in the
middle here what if we tried this and
what if we tried this and then we're
going to have post-mortem which is not
super fun but we're learning new things
and here's the big word we're practicing
new ways of being intimate with one
another and remember intimacy is not
about
how we have sex intimacy is
i'm bridging the gap
of discomfort i'm willing to bridge that
gap do you see me
and do you still love what you see
and that's hard and we often i find in
relation my own relationship all
relationships
that's a recurring question a recurring
thing do you see me and do you still
love me
lacey you're awesome i've got the
highest hopes for your marriage please
let me know i want you to read through
this book let me know how
the homework assignments go on the back
end reach back out to me and if you want
to call back on the show and we can keep
this conversation going i would love
that